[Musica]
qui al ted lo sappiamo bene
nella vita ci sono anche gli imprevisti
io avevo più o meno 17 anni quando
durante una passeggiata sul lago di
arona
mi si è materializzato all'improvviso il
primo è sicuramente anche il più grande
imprevisto riguardante la mia vita
professionale
in quel momento ero un giovane
pallavolista che come tutti i miei
coetanei coltivava la volontà di
realizzare un proprio sogno un proprio
ideale quello di essere un giocatore
protagonista all'interno di una squadra
di eccellenze
durante questa passeggiata era più o
meno giugno 86 il mio allenatore julio
velasco mi mise di fronte all'imprevisto
non avrei potuto raggiungere
l'eccellenza se continuavo a giocare nel
ruolo di palleggiatore durante questa
passeggiata velasco mi disse lorenzo si
accetti una nuova sfida si accetti di
cambiare ruolo
nell'arco di due anni sei nazionale come
schiacciatore sarebbe un po come dire ad
un violinista che per affermarsi a
livello internazionale deve cambiare e
iniziare a suonare il pianoforte
nell'immediato questa proposta mi sembra
inaccettabile
ma soprattutto mi sembrò una proposta
incoerente sì perché lui mi aveva sempre
cercato e voluto
nel ruolo di palleggiatore ed io fino a
qualche giorno prima
fino al giorno precedente mi allenavo in
quel ruolo per cercare di diventarlo
chiaramente i fatti mi dicevano che non
avevo nessun altra opportunità che se
realmente volevo alimentare questo mio
grande desiderio se realmente volevo
raggiungere quello che era il mio sogno
dovevo accettare di cambiare e diventare
uno schiacciatore poi questa scommessa
l'abbiamo vinta entrambi perché
solamente dopo un anno ero lì nazionale
a giocare nel nuovo ruolo quindi
abbracciai questa nuova sfida
decisi di affrontare questo imprevisto
credendo molto in me stesso e fidandomi
di velasco fino a farlo diventare il mio
mentore gli imprevisti possono essere
delle grandi opportunità l'opportunità
di abbandonare una parte di noi e di
consolidarne delle altre ma per riuscire
a cogliere queste occasioni che si
possono materializzare in qualsiasi
momento della nostra vita
dobbiamo avere il coraggio di affrontare
dobbiamo avere il coraggio di superare
quelli che sono considerati i nostri
limiti mentali che quasi sempre si auto
creiamo e quasi sempre ci auto
alimentiamo uno su tutti la trappola
della coerenza perché la coerenza e
quella parte razionale di noi che ci
porta a proteggere le scelte
precedentemente fatte perché ci porta a
rimanere
ancorati in maniera importante alle
nostre battute abitudini infatti la
coerenza spesso viene abbinata alle
persone intellettualmente stabili mentre
l'incoerenza viene riconosciuta come un
tratto della personalità negativo ma
quando la coerenza stessa diventa il
nostro nemico numero uno per raggiungere
i nostri obiettivi
allora dobbiamo avere il coraggio di
fare delle scelte incoerenti l'outsider
è una persona che a questo tipo di
caratteristiche l'outsider ha il
coraggio
l'outsider ha la forza di abbandonare
una parte di se stesso alla curiosità
alla volontà di immergersi in un'area di
incertezza consapevole della propria
forza e consapevole della propria
vocazione
ed è proprio in questo momento quando
noi scopriamo quella che è la nostra
vera essenza che nasce la grande sfida
con noi stessi che nasce quel desiderio
di portare a termine il percorso che noi
abbiamo iniziato
e allora e da quel momento lì e da quel
preciso istante quando noi riscopriamo
la nostra vera essenza che abbiamo la
responsabilità di dare sempre il meglio
di noi stessi di cercare di superare
tutti i nostri limiti
affinché noi riusciamo a raggiungere
quello che noi ci siamo prefissati
abbiamo la responsabilità di provare di
riprovare fino a quando il nostro
traguardo di vesta diventa concreto la
sconfitta
non è contemplata l'essenza della vita è
che o vinciamo o impariamo ma non
perdiamo mai
noi